so you're uh bored at home are you
ah nothing to do
yeah we're heading towards the winter
you know what i mean there's a lot of
indoors time why don't you play a little
game called rage shadow legends you
could be waiting to get your hair cut
you know in the barbers you could play a
raid then you can play a raid while
you're in an uber in a restaurant you
know if you're bored of the person who
you're talking to that always helps and
if you're going to do that use the link
in my description i know a lot of yous
out there have been waiting a baited
breath wondering what my favorite bit
about raid is well i'll not keep this
waiting any longer the doom tower
the doom tower as it happens well you've
never tried it what is wrong with you
it's basically a big prison and it was
working out well for everyone for quite
a while you know keeping the bodies in
but now see roth is back in the world
let's just say the prison ain't like it
used to be but luckily they've got
people like me and you to get in there
and crack a few heads and i do love
cracking heads and we're gonna crack a
few heads right now with my new champion
mage killer if only this was real life
they don't make them like that on earth
let battle commence flow like a
butterfly sting like a bee that actually
worked quite well god me and this other
girl are kicking ass i'm gonna get this
one there you go dead i'm doing major
damage here and as we know the fastest
way to level up your champion is through
farming on the campaign victory is mine
i know what you're thinking what else is
new and rare bright well don't call me
bry
that's my friends all right there's
plenty new things if you must know we've
got special events every day for you
awesome new champions all the time but
the big update is the guardian ring it's
a huge new feature that gives you a load
of different ways to use your champions
including a whole faction guardian
system which is a new way to get
legendary champions that you missed out
on previously and an entirely new way to
upgrade your favorite ones it's a
massive deal and it's something that
myself and raid are very excited for
with all these updates raid has never
been in a better place with more giant
updates around the corner there's never
been a better time to jump into raid and
if you want an even bigger head start
hit the link in the description or scan
the qr code new players will get an epic
hero in chonaroo who was amazing in the
doom tower as well as 200k silver one xp
boost and one energy refill and as well
as that one inch in short so you can
summon a champion as soon as you get in
the game so what are you waiting for hit
the link in the description below and
check out raid but for now enjoy the
podcast
[Music]
it's august 18 1960 cassius clay of the
united states takes on ziggy petrikovsky
of poland in the finals of the olympic
light heavyweight boxing championship in
rome
cassius like lightning in there an
avalanche of leather sends pietrakowski
into the ropes clay is way ahead on
points and he knows it he's boxing with
all the confidence in the world
realizing he is only moments away from
the gold medal
and there's the bell ending the fight
cassius clay has presented the coveted
gold medal for his tremendous victory in
the light heavyweight division of the
olympic boxing championships
i'm defeating america's so-called
threats or enemies and the flag is going
on
and i don't hook the world for america i
took my gold medal thought i'd invented
something i said man i know i'm gonna
get my people freedom there i'm the
champion of the whole world olympic
champion i know i can eat downtown now
and i went downtown that they had my big
old metal on and went no restaurants at
that time black things weren't
integrated the black folks couldn't eat
downtown the lady said we don't serve
negroes and i had to leave that
restaurant in my hometown where i went
to church and served in their
christianity and fought my daddy fault
in all the wars just wanted to go middle
and couldn't eat downtown i said
something's wrong wrong
why do you insist on being called
muhammad ali now that's my original name
that's a black man named cassius clay
was my slave name i'm no longer slave
you told me your name was cassius clay a
few years ago my name was cassius clay
my name is muhammad ali and you will
announce it right there in the end of
that ring after the fight if you don't
do it now mr muhammad ali has just
refused to be inducted into the united
states armed forces you're my opposing
when i'm on freedom you're my opposing
when i want justice you're my opponent
equality you won't even stand up for me
in america for my religious police and
you want me to go somewhere and fight
but you won't even stand up for me here
at home i want to believe that i'm that
guy my ego tells me that but the reality
of it is i love this life that i have i
might not want to give this up just to
prove that i'm a tough guy but i'll
leave wood
ali i'll fight you till he die you have
to kill him
he's not gonna quit when you see
greatness then you know that's not me
at least a giant
[Music]
know they're not alive
i can drown the drink of water and kill
a dead tree wait till you see muhammad
ali i'ma show you how great i am
[Music]
welcome back to the pain game podcast
today's guest is the grandson of the
greatest fighter of all time
muhammad ali it's nico ali walsh welcome
to show me thank you so much for having
me it's a pleasure and uh thank you for
getting up at 10 a.m las vegas time to
make this work for me this really goes
back to my school days when i was like
an eight-year-old kid in the library and
looking at books and reading about the
greatest boxer of all time um
and and to say that you're carrying this
on for your grandfather it's amazing and
what makes it even more special is you
genuinely have talent from what i've
seen and you're getting trained by the
same coaches tyson fury um no pressure
everything uh everything's set up for
you to win hopefully but um how long
have you been boxing for now well i was
i would mess around in the ring since i
was a little little kid um i was doing
exhibitions and and whatnot for like
cancer child
children's cancer events and that kind
of thing but
i i want to say i took it serious when i
was 14. well that's good because
unfortunately in boxing uh very few seem
to make it and unless they start young
like was it like anthony joshua and
deontay wilder are a couple of
exceptions and they're like giant
athletes
um the rest uh it's it's from childhood
so like i know you
have another uh
second generation uh boxer uh in the
family leila who obviously went on to
become a legend in women's boxing how
are the family feeling about you
following the family job so to speak
like my mom didn't want me didn't want
me to box obviously because she's my mom
uh you know and i would say the women in
my family didn't want to see me you know
getting hurt and that kind of thing
but the main person in my family who
encouraged me to box and actually pushed
me towards it was my grandfather and
that's really all i needed
was you know his blessing and i said
okay this is what i'm gonna do wow i
mean
it almost feels like i'm speaking to
muhammad ali himself
you know because this is the closest
thing i'm ever going to get and um
he meant so much to so many people and
i'm sure you guys
feel the love around the world still if
anything you know even after his passing
it almost feels like he's um
i don't know like
the
god of boxing like this guy
his his shadow looms over the entire
spot like yeah i mean it's it's amazing
it's an honor that i'm you know that i'm
i'm witnessing the love and and i get to
appreciate it because at the end of the
day
he meant a great deal to the world but
to me he's just my grandfather but it
means so much to me to know that so many
people loved someone that i just see as
family
so it's it's really awesome and i i've
seen some of the photographs of you and
him as
a
kid and it's very heartwarming
you did get a totally different angle to
him than everybody else you know we seen
you know the smooth talker
the guy who made everyone laugh the guy
who made everyone cheer
and
the guy who flipped people's emotions
from wanting to lose to wanting them to
win over the years and
um
and you got granddad uh what was he like
as a granddad i would say i didn't
receive the side the braggadocious and
like yelling side of him you know that
side that he gave like joe frazier and
george foreman i didn't see that side
but i saw the funny side the
heartwarming side that was what i grew
up with and uh obviously he didn't speak
as much
um growing up with me as he did in his
interviews but when he did it was just i
mean we were constantly laughing
together so what you guys saw on tape
that's the way he was he was just such a
genuine person yeah that i i seen some
clips of him later on in his life and
that sense of humor definitely carried
through i've seen him playing jokes on
interviewers
where um
i think there was one of his daughters
was saying like oh there's this part of
his condition that makes him do this and
then he like
looked at it
you know make jokes at the wrong time
but you know he was just so funny when
did you realize he wasn't just your
grandfather how early can you remember
that i remember i was 12 years old and
he had a 70th birthday bash here in las
vegas
and
all these celebrities that i looked up
to you know all these celebrities that i
listened to their music i watched their
films they were all at birthday party
and i was like what are these guys doing
at my grandfather's birthday party
that's so weird and they're all singing
him happy birthday
so i started realizing then that you
know a lot of people know him not just
people in in my neighborhood because
that's what i thought before and did
people treat you differently because you
were you know his grandson yeah i've
always i've always felt the pressure of
being his grandson you know if i didn't
get into boxing um i would have felt it
in any
category of of life because even when i
was in school as a little kid i felt the
pressure of you know getting good grades
and acting right just because of my
grandfather yeah uh when i watched your
post fight interviews i was like okay
there's confidence there but it ain't it
you're very much you're your own guy and
you're quite a humble guy actually very
respectful but very intelligent that
really came across i mean how old are
you again
i just turned 21 in july wow
i mean you're very grounded um is who
who who do you think has made you like
that is it your mother yeah you know
what my mom is uh
obviously my grandfather is my mom's dad
and she's she's the twin as everybody
calls her um and uh yeah no she
obviously
we we grew up with my grandfather and uh
she just took all the lessons that he
taught her and then she taught me them i
would say i got it from from my mom and
she got it from him i seen her cheering
you on in the crowd and you know in your
first few couple of fights and the crowd
chanting early it was it was just so
powerful i mean what did that feel like
to be in that ring and have people
chanting ali i mean that that that was
the my first fight in that was
crazy i mean you know there were so many
aspects of that fight that were just so
like destined to happen i was wearing my
grandfather's shorts for that fight wow
and uh i wasn't even supposed to be
wearing those shorts i just i brought
them on my trip uh as a memento and uh
my my shorts that i was supposed to wear
ended up not being ready um so i ended
up having to having to wear my
grandfather's shorts and just hearing
his name being chanted is something i've
only seen in black and white films you
know of like
joe frazier fights and and whatnot so
hearing his name being chanted just it
like brought him back for the night he
was he was completely like i felt like
he was there that night bro i'm getting
like goosebumps like honestly like yeah
i i get goosebumps every time i think
about it because it's so it was so weird
it felt so surreal yeah the emotion in
the room i it really came through the
screen like to see because the camera
was on your mother a lot as well and
that whenever they do that obviously
there's emotion there because we feel
like we know your family through all of
the documentaries and your mother's a
very good speaker as well i know so like
feel like we we kind of know you guys um
and yeah it was just heartwarming and i
think everyone
naturally is gonna root for you to do
well now
um yeah how do you feel
you did in those first couple of fights
so far well i loved my first fight you
know that was my first time being out on
that kind of stage and i felt like i
handled the pressure and and the crowd
very well it didn't affect me um at all
really um because i just felt so much
power on my shoulders you know
carrying the legacy you know my family
support everyone else's support
and uh my second fight went very well
and i'm looking on this this next fight
that i have coming up december 11th is
at madison square garden
so you know my
father had eight fights there he fought
his first fight with joe frazier was
there so it's like just repeating
history like this is just it takes away
all the fear and pressure a normal boxer
would have and it's like it's it's
empowering you know it really is i love
i love the way you're looking at this
because you know some people who aren't
mentally as strong as you
would crumble potentially under this and
the fact that you're seeing this all as
a positive is fantastic because you know
i just seen the other day um the ufc are
having an event in madison square garden
and
you had one of the champions talking
about what madison square garden means
and one of the four
names um they named the wrestler they
named a rock band and muhammad ali
and you know that's his that's his place
that you're going to really so yeah
your ability to deal with pressure
immediately struck me because there was
no waiting around there was no
tentativeness in the in the ring it was
all business the minute that bell went
and you throw
if i was to compare you to any boxer
i've seen recently you kind of reminded
me a bit of ryan garcia you really you
you really throw your punches like you
put everything into them when you let it
go
um
and
you've got you've got the speed and
you've got
good feet naturally it's in the it's in
the genes um
is that a deliberate thing in terms of
you know the way you move uh is that a
conscious thing or is that just how you
feel comfortable or honestly um as much
as people say i've been floating uh
like a butterfly in the ring
it's it's solely because of my trainer
sugar hill that's the style he teaches
and you know he's one of the people that
uh again you know i'm blessed that i'm
able to deal with this pressure you know
it's it's it's a lot of pressure
and uh i didn't know if i'd be able to
handle it but i i'm here and i'm able to
handle it and and uh it's it's solely
because of the way i was raised and how
i'm trained so i've got to thank sugar
for you know the way that i've been
moving the way i've been performing you
know despite you coming across as a
really nice guy and
when when i've seen people interview you
you've got that youthful
excitement and you're enjoying this
whole process but you know naturally
there's a bad man underneath that and in
the ring that comes out and i was sort
of wondering like
do you think as your career goes on
that side of you will come out more when
the competitiveness gets intensified and
people may be on your level a bit more
absolutely um you know i'm i've always
been a fan of watching
trash you know my grandfather
being the main one tyson fury being you
know the king of trash talking of this
generation
and uh it's all to sell fights and you
know it takes it takes an animal to get
into the ring you know for to excel in
the ring i would say it's very
interesting because you look at someone
like mike tyson who was an animal in the
ring and outside the ring you see you
would see in interviews he was just
very mean you know but that's not that's
not the way he is you know but my
grandfather fought with like love i
would say and it's very strange to say
that you're fighting somebody with with
love but that's that's kind of what he
did he was fighting for his people and
for his religion so i would say that's
the same thing with me you know that's
deep like and and i agree with you i
think when i watched um your
grandfather's fights his ability to take
punishment his ability to get up and
keep going
um
he it had to be out of love because
fear doesn't carry you through what he
went through and um i think ironically
you mentioned mike tyson and i've heard
mike tyson describe his feelings in the
ring and how fearful he was at times and
how it made him as aggressive as he had
to be
but i don't know if you've heard mike
speak on your grandfather i mean i have
powerful
like very
geez when when when you can reduce a a
bad man like mike tyson to tears just
merely speaking on him
and uh to quote him i think he said i'm
afraid to go to the places that muhammad
ali would go to and he was a giant and
he was willing to die to prove his point
um that sort of thing it's like
wow that's when you know you're a legend
when when today's generation's legend
mike tyson
looks at ali as if i i can't even i
can't even compare
you know that's very interesting it's
it's very interesting and i've always
loved seeing you know his interviews
talking about my grandfather and you
know it's most people most boxers fight
out of aggression they fight out of fear
um believe it or not but you get people
like my grandfather and
people like manny pacquiao they fight
out of love and i i really do believe
that when you reach that level of
fighting out of love you're able to
excel far beyond uh the the average
person and i think that this is where
tyson fury's recent success may have
come in because now that he's um
trying to win fights in in the name of
mental health and how he channels that
he said like when i get knocked down i
think if i get up i'm showing all those
people out there what they can do and um
yeah it's
the parallels between fury and ali um
don't get me wrong i mean
there's a difference but it is nice to
see that there are completely yeah
there's yeah there's there's
similarities he's one of my favorite
fighters
yeah yeah definitely and you know it's
hard fighting for one person yourself
you know you get people like my
grandfather who's like a larger than
life figure and you wonder why why does
he seem like such a king why does he
seem so large it's because he had he
stood for everybody you know um and
tyson fury does that he stands for all
people suffering with mental health and
you know
and that's why
he seems like a larger than life figure
today it's the people that fight for
everyone else that that they get to that
point that legendary status what did you
think of tyson fury's last fight you
know the the the getting up multiple
times and finishing deontay
again it shades of your grandfather what
was it like watching that for you i
think you were there if i'm right yeah i
i was there and it was so nerve-wracking
because you know obviously i have a
vested interest in him
and you know sugar who's training him so
and
um it was such an amazing fight i i
truly do believe that tyson fury's top
five heavyweights of all time and uh
yeah i mean that was just an amazing
fight and like i said he fights for more
than just himself that's why he's able
to do the things that he can do i would
uh i would love to go back in time with
you and uh to a time where you and i
weren't alive but i'm sure we've both
heard a lot and i'm sure you've heard a
lot more than i have uh and talk about
your grandfather's life a bit more is
that okay bro yeah
uh uh because i've been watching
documentaries and all sorts and um yeah
and like america back then seemed like
such a different place he was from uh
louisville
and when you talk when he when when
muhammad would talk about you know not
being able to be served
in in restaurants despite being an
olympic champion
you know that's that's quite
mind-blowing for me now because of the
world we live in and have your family
educated you on sort of what he would
face back then yeah i mean i i was i was
five years old learning about the civil
rights movement and learning about my
grandfather's part in it
so you know i would say my grandfather
had such strong conviction
towards race and religion and that's
exactly how i was raised that's exactly
how i am so i know all about that stuff
and you're right i mean the world we
live in today is you know so different
compared to the world he grew up in
for him to
join uh islam uh at the time you know
we've
you got athletes these days sort of um
trying to make statements but you know
that was a shock it was a shock to the
to the world like who does this guy
think he is and they consistently
kept calling him cassius clay and and
many of his even black fighters who he
was fighting refused to call him
muhammad and it felt like there was a
strong dislike from the mainstream media
that this guy was as good as he was
because he was sort of a thorn in the
side of the status quo and he had to
face that every day yeah i mean it's you
know the the what's my name fight is
what they call it with ernie tyrell and
uh every time someone didn't call him by
his name he
destroyed him because he was very
serious about that and i never saw my
grandfather as serious as he was during
the earning to rail fight he was very
serious and he punished him he could
have taken him out um early on i believe
but
he
he just punished him for several rounds
and that's just shows how how uh serious
he was about his religion yeah he he
used fighting as a way of making sending
message out there of right you will
respect us you will respect our religion
you will respect my people
and um yeah it it brought
sport into a whole new
place where all of a sudden you know
sport is seen as something where we take
our mind off real life we
forget about our religion and our
politics and our struggles and we you
know what watch it eat popcorn and think
nothing you know but he
made it impossible to ignore he he he
was like we've got issues and i'm gonna
force people
to listen through
my winning and being heavyweight
champion i guess to this day no one's
done anything even remotely close
because no one's willing to
sacrifice and put themselves out there
to be shot at almost quite literally
yeah put themselves on the chopping
block and go well you know i'm going to
use my fame and my name to
um promote a different way of life and i
mean he must have feared for his life
yeah i mean it takes i mean a ton of
courage even even still today to stick
up for something like that something
that can completely ruin your career and
it did for him you know it took it took
years off of his boxing life
so it takes a lot of courage but you
know i mean
he's he's been like
i i heard my grandfather was like shot
at one time
but you know you look at the people like
during his era malcolm x martin luther
king i mean what happened to these
people these people that took a stand
they they got assassinated so i know he
must have feared for his life and you
know he was taking a stand that was
literally life or death you know it
could have
someone could have assassinated him at
any point and i wouldn't be here today
uh to talk about it yeah as heavyweight
champion of the world you're an idol and
if and you know the the government know
that more than anyone and if we've got
this idol standing up and saying don't
go to war
don't join the army don't go to vietnam
they ain't done nothing to us like
they're like oh a little too much truth
in the air from the sky and i i i mean
it's it's quite surprising that he
wasn't assassinated to be fair because
they drafted him in the army as a
a tool to be like
um you know as they've done with many
athletes in the past they've look guys
look kids everyone go and join the army
your favorite baseball player basketball
player fighters there and he was not
having none of it um how courageous you
know to say no to that and
there's a clip way standing up in front
of all of these people in the crowd and
obviously mainly white people in and
arguing with them and justifying
explaining you know like you're the ones
not
giving me my rights i'm you know i'm uh
why am i going to go and fight for you
exactly exactly so they banned him from
fighting uh for a few years and in the
prime of his career which was a real
shame looking back at it um yeah because
you know he was uh a different fighter
when he came back
um but he evolved and he adapted and
i i think people have a lot of respect
for the fact that he managed to do that
because he became a tough fighter rather
than the showboater
yeah yeah you know unfortunately that
made for more brutal fights but
he
he wouldn't back down it's the same in
life
you just wouldn't back then obviously a
lot of people in society turned on him
right now muhammad ali is a hero and i
think you know a lot of people watching
this won't really understand like at the
time there was a smear campaign against
him the government and everyone was
trying to dirty his name and say this
guy won't fight for you and make him
seem
as negative as humanly possible and only
i feel like when the vietnam war was um
proven to be a mistake did people start
to wake up and realize hang on a second
this guy had the right idea have you
spoken to your family about this time
and and what that was like we i mean
we've spoken on it you know throughout
my entire life
literally and uh you know that's a
that's a that's what separates my
grandfather from not only being a boxer
but just being the kind of human he was
uh was what he stood for outside of
boxing you know against the war you know
for civil rights he just he put it all
on the line and he was willing literally
to give up his life for it and you just
don't see a lot of people in history
that are willing to do that um that's
what separated him and the biggest thing
is that after all that happened after
they stripped him of his title and they
were about to put him in in prison you
know
sentenced to five years i think
yeah yeah and then after all that after
that sentence got turned over aft still
after that he came back and became
heavyweight champion of the world again
and i think that's why people respect
him so much because he was able to throw
away everything for standing up for
something and he was able to gain it all
back
uh just based off of
his conviction alone yeah it's truly
amazing like to to you know to defy the
odds in the first place and beat sonny
liston
uh yeah
you know no one thought that would
happen he was one of the biggest
underdogs in fight history uh sunny
listen was like the mike tyson of the
era for those who don't know
and then
there was more sunny listings when he
came back
uh from his back yeah three years out of
the game you know sitting and not
training
and then all of these guys like these
killers like joe frazier and george
foreman are waiting for him and they
look indestructible
and then
he comes out um after nearly going to
jail for but standing up for people and
then beats these unbeatable guys once
again um
it's just uh it's staggering i mean um
what kind of relationship did he have
with people like martin luther king and
malcolm x from what i heard um they were
very close i remember hearing stories uh
when i was young that my grandfather was
so
so devastated hearing about the passing
of
malcolm x um because he was so he was so
close to these guys even though
even though martin luther king wasn't
muslim you know he was still his
brother-in-law
arms
because they stood for something and uh
yeah i just i i know that time that time
period must have been super devastating
for my grandfather seeing his friends
his actual friends being assassinated
for
no reason for just sticking up for what
they believe in and that's what he was
doing it must have been scary and he
continued to do it you know and and most
people would have been like listen these
guys are getting
killed you know for doing what i'm doing
right now i'm gonna stop and he didn't
stop so um
yeah i mean it's a lot of courage when i
think of my grandfather i just think of
courage that's it that's you've nailed
it man honestly true courage and uh you
watch your story and you watch his
fights and you just think
how did this guy even exist like how do
i it really does it blows my mind some
of the things he did in the wa and like
you say
like martin luther king i've seen one
little clip of them together and um you
know obviously different religions but
both standing together and showing love
for one another it was a really
heartwarming moment actually that the
fact that he didn't go quiet i mean look
if when those two guys get shot in the
way that they did uh
99.9 other people would have been like
i'm gonna be a bit more quieter about
this yeah exactly there were some great
fights um
the george foreman one um and the
rivalry with joe frazier really feel
like they stick out to me because those
were the guys who
just seemed unbeatable at the time
what is it like for you watching those
fights back because they are
you know brutal
the skill the will everything that went
into them it it's hard to watch actually
sometimes and that's very rare i say
that about boxing but it's just brutal
and i think it was so brutal because uh
my grandfather was my grandfather but he
was also it felt like he was the world's
friend everyone felt like they knew him
and uh watching him get beat even you
know in his later days was like
devastating it was hard to watch
um i didn't even watch i i don't even
watch those fights
but i you know the rumble in the jungle
uh with george foreman was my favorite
fight of his because it just stood for a
lot more than just the fight and i would
actually watch that with my grandfather
a ton of times what was it like to be
there and do that with your grandfather
he i mean he would get he would be doing
whatever he would be you know having a
good time if i put on that tape on my
phone he would be locked in and we would
just be staring at my phone for the next
30 minutes watching the fight
and i would ask him like certain things
i would say hey what did you say to this
guy here what did you do this because he
would talk while he while he fought but
certain things he didn't remember and uh
yeah i mean it was just so so much fun
uh watching watching you know the
greatest fight of all time in my opinion
uh with who i believe to be the greatest
fighter of all time that's truly special
me honestly um and and i've i've spoken
to some people about you coming on and
the the word the greatest i mean yes he
said the greatest and it almost became a
nickname as much but it it was it was
true and because great great isn't just
about your ability in the ring great
isn't about beating every generation
that come after you to me i think
greatness is like it's about leaving
that legacy and and
fighting everyone in their prime going
after anyone and everyone he really
showed that he was never gonna back down
to
anyone
and like i feel like now we're in an era
where fighters are very selective and
clever and
it's completely different i mean this
guy was out here just
anyone wants a pop in it let's go you
know and that that yeah people were
terrified of george foreman you know
rightly so i know someone who met him
and they were like you like this guy was
huge like just chiseled
people were terrified of this guy i
recently remember the the news reporter
saying
old ally got no chance yada yada
justified the odds so many times it
really it's like a superhero story when
your grandfather passed what what was um
obviously a very sad time for the family
but how how did the family deal with
that that was another time period where
i was just like it was a total blur
um but it was it was such
a heartwarming experience
um
just seeing how people reacted
to him him passing and seeing the
streets flooded with people uh in
louisville was just i mean like it feels
like a dream now because that whole time
period was just so blurry to me probably
you wouldn't have it it was just so
hectic and sad but you know
i was
15 i was 15. that makes sense you know
obviously you're a young guy even now
but like at 15 to lose someone who means
so much to you guys it
your brain probably was protecting you
from sort of
the operation
you know i don't remember small details
but you know i'm glad because it was a
very it was a very sad time and uh what
i do remember was great it was it was
what i do remember it was like a
celebration seeing the people cheer him
on in the streets the whole world
stopped it felt like you know it's it's
it's an honor and i know he would have
been extremely happy to see that he left
that kind of impact on people there's a
few uh
he had a few wives and he had uh
multiple children obviously so were you
guys able to come together or was it
quite uh divided at the time or how did
that work my grandfather brought us all
together um you know we were always you
know thanksgiving everyone would be at
his house thanksgivings we would go to
his house his birthday we would go to
his house and because we because my
immediate family lived so close he lived
in arizona we would constantly be
driving down there uh to his house but
yeah no he made our family close he made
our family tight and that's why our
family is the way it is uh now he just
he brought us all together it's it's
tricky for
for any family when it's a bit like that
that's lovely that you guys were able to
have that closeness um despite obviously
people having different mothers or what
whatever the situation was
do you think he had many regrets i don't
know
um you know he was like it seemed like
his only fault was women
and uh
he just he's human he's loved he is
human after all
exactly exactly so he had to have he had
to have something and if he didn't have
women then i personally don't know what
it would be i'm sure he doesn't regret
anything uh
because everything turned out the way it
was supposed to be and i'm very happy uh
that it turned out the way it did yeah
the i mean the guy was an incredibly
handsome six foot three charismatic dude
so i mean it must have been hard button
uh button off the advances you know
like definitely definitely before
he became champion but even after
champion you know you had to get a
security team to keep off uh the
beautiful women wow
that's so funny
yeah because i mean obviously
he was a religious man but like you know
no no man is uh perfect perfect nobody's
fair play at home i mean did you follow
in the footsteps and and obviously um
you know join islam yourself yeah no i
was born and raised uh to be muslim and
uh
like i said you know the way my
grandfather was that's exactly how i am
in terms of conviction with race and
religion you know because i'm i'm
biracial myself my mom being black and
my dad being white um i'm muslim my
mom's muslim uh my my family's muslim so
and and we're practicing muslims so uh
yeah i'm just i'm i'm proud that i was
raised the way i am to stay uh true to
that uh are your mother and father still
together yes
did you growing up um biracial um did
that present any challenges to you
coming from such a famous family but
obviously not necessarily looking
exactly like your grandfather yeah of
course you know it it's it shows uh you
know sometimes people say stuff uh when
i was little people would say stuff but
at the end of the day that doesn't it it
would never really bother me because um
me and my grandfather were so close if
if we were like
distant and we were not close at all it
would definitely bother me but um my
grandfather loved me um i loved him and
you know we just had the greatest of
times together and uh you know even my
grandfather early on in his career he
said things along the lines of um you
shouldn't
mix races you should stick with your own
races and even later on in his life he
took back that statement you know before
i was even born he took back that
statement and he loved me and my brother
and uh so i i
don't worry about uh the stuff people
say in terms of that yeah there was a
few interviews where he would say things
and and then you see him later on in
your life in his life and you're like
yeah you softened and you evolved and
you know at that time and that's what
it's all about yeah it
when i listened to was it elijah
muhammad and then malcolm x
it felt like to me at least then this is
someone who knows very little about
islam but that one of them had a bit
more of a progressive attitude towards
you know like elijah muhammad seemed an
old-school
kind of guy for one yeah a word
and yeah like everything evolves and as
i guess religion does too and uh it's
nice that
you i mean i suppose you can learn more
about him even now to this day as you
get older because what i found after
i've lost people in my life um i've i've
lost a parent and what you find is as
you get older
you weirdly reconnect with them through
experiences of becoming older yourself
and you're like oh so when you're going
into your fights in your mid-20s late
20s i'm sure you're gonna be kind of
having little conversations with him in
your head almost of like oh well if this
is what you were feeling when you were
having this fight or yeah and you know
what
there's there's a quote that i was
actually saying before my last fight the
quote is uh a man is not dead while his
name is still spoken
and
since i've started fighting everyone's
been speaking about my grandfather
obviously they've been speaking about me
being his grandson but that being said
my grandfather uh is still alive he's
still very much alive and around as long
as people are talking about him and
that's the way that's the way it feels
so i do feel like i'm reconnecting with
him and you know honestly fighting might
even be healthy for me in
in grieving honestly because it's just
uh
i i feel close i feel close to him i
feel closer to him uh now
uh than ever honestly i'm not surprised
in the slightest mate because i'm after
my first uh i do a little bit of boxing
you know and after my first uh spa
i got my head punched in as as you do
and uh
i had a good cry afterwards because i
was thinking about my mother and just
like
fighting is so
emotional at times um especially if
you're losing and um yeah i can totally
i can totally imagine
that closeness
um coming back because i mean you're
just going to be able to empathize with
so much of his story now when you go
back and you know watch those first
fights and almost feel like
you know what it was like for him a
little bit more than what you ever could
have done had you not have been a boxer
it's it's very true it's very true
what is uh the crunk gym like because we
hear it's very
um you know it's all about knockouts
and uh you've proved that sugar hill
seems to be a very smart guy so what is
it like training with him it's amazing
you know uh it's it's amazing on a
spiritual side of things because he's
continuing the legacy of his uncle
emanuel stewart which i believe is one
of the greatest boxing trainers of all
time and you know here i am uh in the
shadow of my grandfather who's one of
the great who is the greatest fighter of
all time to me
and uh he's able to talk to me about
these things and he's able to teach me
about boxing which i'm
a lot more
understanding i'm a lot more
eager to listen to him when i know he
knows what i'm going through in terms of
continuing a legacy so i just feel like
we're able to connect very easily and
i'm able to learn learn from him very
well uh because because of that
connection
and what kind of fighter do you think
you're going to evolve into i think i'm
going gonna be aggressive i think i'm
definitely gonna have my own unique
style um but definitely with sugar in my
corner uh he likes knockouts and that's
that's what we're looking to do you know
at all times and uh yeah i'm just i'm
looking forward to evolving i've only
you know i've only been with sugar for a
couple months so
you know the next fight is going to be
very special you know because when i
watched you
um
you know not not being critical because
it's your first couple of fights but i
was like
this guy ain't throwing the job
that much competitive
like a lot of fighters his job like you
know then you were all in
and it was spectacular but i was worried
i'm like this kid might uh might be too
aggressive you know i mean like yeah so
no you know i'm still i'm still learning
there's so many mistakes that i've made
you know little mistakes i've only been
with him for a couple months i'm just
imagining now what am i going to look
like after being with him for a year
what about two years and uh you could
see his work on display with tyson fury
uh with the way he did his last two
fights you can see the way sugar works
sugar's transformed tyson in my opinion
we're seeing a whole uh another site
he's so much scarier than he's ever been
in fact now now that he's
you know he's putting
his weight through his punches and and
leaning on people and just roughing them
up that's all sugar tea that's all sugar
teaches yeah it's it's proper pro boxing
as opposed to the amateur style which is
obviously a lot more yeah point fighting
so you were with other trainers before
him then um were they the the like
amateur trainers yeah before i was with
sugar i was with abel sanchez
in big bear who was triple g's former
trainer
and uh i was with him for a couple
months
i learned a ton from him and then i went
straight from him with uh sugar and uh
yeah i mean i'm just i feel like i'm
able to learn very quickly from from
sugar so you know there's no telling
where i can go you know the more time i
spend with him the more i learn from him
and uh what uh how did you get connected
with uh with uh sugar was this anointed
uh this is this like uh this guy's the
grandson of muhammad ali we gotta get
hold of him type thing or no it was so
weird um
my uncle
my uncle who's now my manager
uh knew
sugar's uncle and uh he knew emmanuel
stewart he actually was the one who took
him to the hospital unfortunately when
um when emanuel stewart um you know
obviously he had cancer
so they my my uncle knew him very well
and uh
he just got in contact with sugar like i
mean the first time me and sugar met it
wasn't like meeting a complete stranger
because our family had known each other
uh previously yeah
there's that familiarity there i guess
and it is so great that you guys are
both
continuing legacies on um which can only
make you understand each other better as
coach and fighter i guess because
emmanuel stewart my god i mean
what he did for lennox lewis for example
um amazing
um i don't know if lennox lewis gets the
title back without him you know so
exactly yeah yeah they they're good at
transforming people and you've got bob
arum behind you as well
um
you really have got some big names
behind you guys
yeah i mean it's just like i'm i'm
repeating history here
i mean
was my grandfather's promoter you know
so it's it's it's crazy it's crazy but
it's it's so cool you know the story
behind all of this
what was it like meeting uh bob and and
getting his support because i mean for
those who don't know bob is
a very old guy but you mean he is he is
a huge
power in the world of boxing uh
obviously bob arum has known my family
for so many years he's traveled with my
mom you know to events and whatnot but
my first time formally meeting him
was right before i signed with top rank
and it was it was with my uncle
and i met him
uh we discussed we had like a little
meeting uh he had people
vet me
uh you know people go watch me in the
gym and see me train and they're like
okay you know this kid isn't this kid
isn't just someone who's looking to make
money or something like that you know
this this kid's got some skill and then
sugar was able to uh give them extra
confidence saying yeah you know what i i
can turn this kid into into something
something good so bob arum took that
chance on me you know he uh allowed me
to sign with top rank and uh yeah i'm
indebted to him where is it you think
that you want to go with this like how
how far do you want to take this boxing
game are you hopeful to be a world
champion one day honestly whatever
wherever sugar takes me
i'm i'm willing i'm willing to go i'm
here i'm here for the journey i love
boxing that's what i'm passionate about
and i'm trying to i'm trying to box not
just for myself but something bigger for
myself
bigger than myself
you know and that gives me the courage
to keep on going so if if sugar takes me
one day to being that world champion
i'll i'll be very happy uh do you think
you you when you say bigger than
yourself do you mean going in a similar
direction your grandfather in terms of
um helping people using your profile
yeah that's all i'm about that's that's
how i was raised and people are going to
start um seeing that because that's
that's how i was raised i know nothing i
know nothing else other than doing that
what kind of things do you think you
might do say if you do make it to the
top of the mountain you know i i don't
even need to make it to the top of the
mountain you know even where i'm at
right now i i have enough of
a little platform to speak on what i'm
uh on what i believe in and you know uh
obviously things that i'm very
passionate about are race and in my
religion and uh being that i am biracial
and you know half of my family is black
you know there's still racism going on
today and i was very vocal about that um
you know
uh on social media when that was going
on here in america um and you know i'm
just anytime i see wrong wrongdoing
anytime i see something that i don't
believe in i'll i'll say something well
that's very powerful and good on you
mate because obviously you know in the
last couple of years there's
the the awful scenes of um george
floyd's death uh were were terrible and
um
you know i wonder what your grandfather
would make of that now you know
for him to know that after all the work
he did things like this are still
occurring in his grandson's
life
yeah i mean you know
nobody will ever racism will never not
exist unfortunately but you know people
like my grandfather put make strides and
make it better people like martin luther
king make it better
and you know during that time that was a
horrible time in you know american
history and and covert was going on but
i was i was out here in vegas protesting
when when that stuff was going on um
during the during the pandemic you know
during the height of kovid and it's
unfortunate that i even had to do that
but you know that's that's what it is
and i feel like that's what my
grandfather would be doing if he was if
he was around yeah when you when you
were protesting what was it like being
amongst the people and um and and making
a stand like that for something you
believe in so passionately
it's very it's it's powerful because you
know it's something that i very uh i i
care about extremely i'm very passionate
about uh a race in in religion um more
so than boxing you know that stuff is
very very important and serious to me um
but unlike how some of the media were
was portraying the protesting it was all
peaceful everyone there and it was great
to see
there were asian americans there there
were mexicans there there were white
people black people it wasn't just black
people protesting against george floyd
it was a whole
you know it was everybody it was a
spectrum of different people and uh that
was great to see and it just shows that
you know it is possible to make you know
these strides even even today you know
what what what's life like for you ev
every
you know week now what what's what's it
like day to day
honestly if i had a camera on me at all
times it would be very very boring as a
21 year old i've never drank or smoked
in my life i've never done drugs um so i
live a very um healthy lifestyle and and
very boring you know after the gym
um i i'm in college so i get my school
work done
and uh that's all uh you know i go from
home to gym home to gym and that's about
it
you know obviously you mentioned your
grandfather had a certain release um do
you have anything that you
sort of i don't know video games what
what what's your thing yeah no
definitely i love playing video games i
unfortunately haven't had any time
lately to play them but i love playing
video games but my vice my my uh escape
would definitely be sweets and that's
what my grandfather's was towards
towards um you know when i knew him yeah
it was sweets i heard it those are hard
to stay away from very hard to stay away
from but yeah everyone's gotta have
something but like it's really great
that you're you're living that dedicated
life because unfortunately
that's the downfall of a lot of boxers
when they don't live the life as they
say what do you think uh of mma i'm just
wondering like do you watch mma a lot or
are you mainly just boxing
i'm mainly boxing but definitely if
there's a big fight going on i have a
ton of
friends that are in the ufc and friends
that are mma fighters so i i really
loved khabib um oh i can imagine
khabib's hero is your grandfather i
don't know if you've seen him say it
yeah yeah i've seen it i've seen him say
that and that was one of the reasons
like i'm biased if someone says
something nice about my grandfather i
automatically like them i don't have to
see anything else
but um yeah i know he was uh truly
amazing
i think he said on the mike tyson
he was on the mike tyson podcast and he
said something about if he could meet
any fighter ever it would have been uh
ali which i thought was really awesome
he's never met him he never met him yeah
i wish i wish i would have known he was
such a big fan you know i he i would
have had him meet him uh while while my
grandfather was still here yeah
well um this is just the start of your
journey um but i'm very excited to see
how it goes
you've got a fight coming up
this december
december 11th yes uh what what is the
opponent like has he been announced yet
he has not been announced yet um i've
heard little things about who it may be
um but at the end of the day sugar
doesn't even like thinking about
opponents he he says if if you train the
way that you're supposed to train it
doesn't matter who they put in front of
you and that's kind of the way that i've
i've started to believe so
it doesn't matter right now who the
opponent is to me at least i i mean i'm
hearing a lot of good things you you
caught your trainer which shows you
believe in him and uh
i mean we've seen
lately obviously with anthony joshua um
if you don't believe in your coach it
can be a nightmare when you get in that
ring
um and you're living the life um i i i
see no reason why you haven't got the
talent to go all the way at me like when
when i watched your first couple of
fights i was like
this is a real fighter here you've got
you've got it all and that
the main thing was that you just
delivered straight up bang like first
round went after him yeah and you know
what maybe you know maybe the approach
might be too aggressive whatever
whatever it may be sugar works on it in
the gym and uh you know this is only my
third fight coming up in december and
it's at madison square garden which is
you know a dream uh but i'm really
excited for this one because i really
feel like i'm gonna look spectacular
this one because it's just more time to
learn with sugar it's more time to you
know correct the mistakes i thought i
made my first two fights
uh from memory you rocked the the white
shorts uh with the stripe
is that gonna be a continuation are you
gonna rock that for the rest of your
career possibly you know i love those
shorts i'ma definitely add a little bit
of a tweak to him uh just to make it a
little bit more myself but you know um
i said i said i i retired my
grandfather's shorts because i wore his
shorts for my first fight
i think that's not entirely
i think i'll wear those again for my
last fight uh whenever that may be
but it's no time soon so those are
definitely locked up for now all right i
i usually uh end these interviews with
with a question and i'm interested to
see how you answer it because i'd like
to ask the same question to you in a few
years after you you know you've
hopefully conquered uh a good few fights
how would you like to be remembered
honestly um i would like to be
remembered by standing for something uh
not just being a boxer that would be uh
a serious loss in my book if i was if if
i'm just remembered as being nico the
boxer um so i want to be able to be
remembered for something more than
boxing something bigger than boxing well
it's been a pleasure talking to you
aniko um
i think that you've got
your head screwed on as we say in the uk
and um yeah
for a 21 year old guy
you speak very well you seem to have it
all in front of you you've got the right
people around you
you know i wish you the best of luck i'm
going to be supporting you for the rest
of your career
and i'm sure you'll make your family
proud man thank you so much thank you
it's a it's a pleasure and um
if everyone wants to follow
the journey i'll put the links for your
socials in the description below
and uh hopefully um if you're ever in
the uk
you're more than welcome to come and uh
we can watch some fights together
absolutely you know the uk was a serious
fan base for my grandfather yes
and they're already it i don't even know
if i should be saying this but they're
already discussing me um
going to the uk next year um so that is
one of you know that would be ridiculous
one of your grandfather's uh most famous
sort of uh press conferences that he did
was in the north of england where i'm
from
and uh with like they couldn't believe
that muhammad ali was there like they
they could not but and even now
that people are like muhammad ali came
here you know and that was what he was
the champion of the world for because he
actually went all over the world and
fought all over the world and i think
that's been
sacrificed uh for more money
unfortunately by fighters nowadays but
maybe that's something you could
continue as well well um
you take care brother and uh i wish you
absolutely the best of luck and i look
forward to seeing your fight on december
the 11th awesome thank you so much for
having me absolute pleasure you take
care man thanks well that was the 21
year old grandson of muhammad ali nico
ali walsh
a really nice kid
um obviously
nowhere near the journey yet of a lot of
the people i interview but
i just i'm a huge fan of muhammad ali
and i really wanted to talk to him about
his grandfather talking about his career
i really enjoyed it the the lad seems
like he's got the right attitude for the
fight game and uh it's going to be
exciting to see what he does next i hope
you enjoyed the interview something a
little different uh if you did enjoy it
hit that like button stay subscribed to
the true jordan youtube channel and i'll
see you on the next
pain game podcast